[Music]
we haven't talked in a little while and
I know you have a son is that right one
boy I do yes how old is he now he's
three he's just turned four and I really
I didn't think I was gonna like being a
mom she went ahead and did I was
dreading this and it turns out to be
pretty cool I was just worried that it'd
be like Oh everything on me I have to do
everything for him but it turns out the
little guys got my back too that's nice
I'm trying to think three four that's a
little bit of a tricky age but he's nice
he's like the other day I was in the
parking lot of Whole Foods having a
mental breakdown has that ever happened
to you
I think we've all had a mental breakdown
somewhere and not necessarily in a Whole
Foods parking lot but well we're just
stressful because somebody like stole my
park my parking space you know here in
LA when someone takes your parking space
that's over it wrecks your day yeah and
there's that store supposed to be all
environmentally nice and it's the most
stressful parking lot ever right so some
guy cuts me off and then I'm all boxed
in and I was just like I can't do this
right now you know that just spiraled
from there my sons in the backseat he's
on his iPhone in his car seat you know
and you never know like how there's an
iphone yeah of course
Conan oh sorry
he's had one since he was like one yeah
get with the program he was born with it
he's attached to his hands so he had so
he's playing with an iPhone in the
backseat you're going down I can't go in
there right now and I just was really
taking it there and my hair is bad today
and I just I have no friends and I just
hear this voice from the backseat he's
like hey mom me and daddy your friends
oh I know some sweet
[Laughter]
I hope I hope that's not what you said
she's here full no I was so moved cuz it
turns out having a family is really
sweet I just looked back into those
little eyes and I was like someone's
getting a new app